try to explain the importance of this
prize to a young person let's say an 11
year old full of curiosity law imagine
that your parents take you on a vacation
during the summer summer break and
you're going to go visit an exciting
City like Stockholm okay and you've
never been there before and so the first
thing you do is you take a map from the
hotel and you're going to help your
family find navassa ship so you have
landmarks on the map it could be the
city hall could be the concert house it
could be the palace and the lost ship
those are like your place cells because
as you pass those landmarks they
recognize your place in space the other
thing you need on that map is longitude
and latitude you need to find a way to
navigate to the Vasa ship in a very
efficient way and the grid cells
function like that navigational chart
they help you judge your distance and
help you find your way so the remarkable
thing is that we don't need to have the
map in our hands we have these maps in
our brain and so I would describe it
that way thanks to our grid in place
cells we don't have to walk around with
a map to help us find our way each time
we visit a city because we have that map
in our house